let's get into the fun fact oh yeah fun  fact gang  geez what a rush cool  there's a chemical compound used in  vanilla flavoring flavoring and scents  come they come from the anal gland of  beavers it's called castorium  it's a substance that is used by it is  the produced by the byproduct of the  beavers caster sac  which is found between the pelvis and  the base of their tail beavis use the  substance which is there  which is usually brown and sticky to  mark the territory  and it's the compound that makes  flavoring and scents  of vanilla comes from the sack of a  beaver  a chemical compound anal sat did you say  anal gland from beavers it's called the  cascasterium  custodian so artificial vanilla comes  from that  so these men are just marking their  territory with just vanilla  scent that's cool to be fair but that's  disgusting it's disgusting but at least  now we know